i i want to see where we take all of
these things people are saying in and
around the nfl and turn it into
meaningful action aimed at making things
better one person taking action desean
watson joining a march in houston and
yeah desean
hey if you've been watching any of the
media coverage you know there is a
physical risk in showing up at a
peaceful protest there's a chance if you
show up in a peaceful protest in the
wrong place at the wrong time when
somebody wants to go out for a walk for
a photo op you're going to get tear
gassed or shot with a rubber bullet and
just because it's a rubber bullet
doesn't change the fact that it's a
bullet folks and it causes serious
damage and causes death in some
situations but you may be cleared out
you never know what's gonna what's gonna
go down at one of these peaceful
protests right you never know when
somebody's gonna decide they don't want
a peaceful protest right now we gotta
clear the streets and we're gonna do it
with force so and we talked yesterday
and you know we kind of joked about it a
little bit that henry ruggs shouldn't be
moving his own furniture this is a guy
who's on the brink of one of the biggest
contracts in nfl history he's getting
online by showing up at something like
this and i applaud him for it no me too
i mean way to go desean watson that's
why you're so freaking awesome right
that's how i like to say my song when i
talk a lot about football well this we
might have to add a verse to it but
i'm not surprised to see deshaun watson
there on the front lines first off
desean watson when you meet him is about
as nice and as caring and humble as a
person as there is that you'll ever meet
and then for a young athlete he handles
himself and then and acts like a mature
37 year old and that was when i was
around him as a rookie in the nfl so he
is wise beyond his years he's an
unbelievable leader uh he does it by
example he's not the biggest rah-rah guy
we don't see him like getting a team
around him before the game and doing all
that that's not what he does but he's
certainly not afraid to speak up and
this is actions speak louder than words
and you know something i talked about
yesterday mike you know i just i was
wondering when we might see a player or
a quarterback go get on the front lines
because i think the more you see this
and the more you see a guy like desean
watson at the front of a peaceful
protest or anything like this like we
talked about all week last week it it it
changes people's views
and makes them think a little bit
differently because he's viewed
differently which isn't right in a lot
of ways but he is and i really applaud
him it's i mean he's the man and you're
right mike he's got a lot to risk he's
about to be the second richest player in
the history of football only behind
patrick mahomes
and look
this process in my mind is changing it's
evolving
statements are good call to action in a
statement is better action
is best now um i made the point earlier
in the week and and look i when i wrote
the item at pft and i think we talked
about it here yesterday hell i can't
remember anymore but i did make the
point that only a handful of coaches had
come out and said anything publicly and
and again i don't want it to be an
exercise in checking a box i don't want
people to issue statements because they
feel like they have to issue statements
but it did seem odd to me that it was
just a few who had issued
passionate meaningful commentary whether
it was brian flores the dolphins coach
who issued the statement on friday that
was very very powerful the frank reich
comments the colts head coach verbalized
his views earlier in the week beyond
that there wasn't all that much now i
i believe more will be coming as soon as
today that will be powerful but one
thing i should have realized i should
have i should have
thrown this dart and made this
prediction that at some point a guy who
has a history of not caring about the
consequences of his words and doing
whatever he believes is right and saying
what he believes is right is our guy
sean payton and sean payton put it in
very blunt plain terms yesterday on
social media with photographs
of george floyd
men who were murdered not killed on
video how many have we not seen
22 weeks from today for change that last
line crosses a bridge that a lot of
people in the nfl are afraid to cross
because they don't want to be on the
wrong side of a tweet or a comment at a
rally and the rallies inevitably will be
coming back they don't want to be
singled out they don't want to be called
out they don't want that 30 percent that
will follow one specific person to the
ends of the earth and maybe currently
are uh
they don't want that and sean payton put
himself in in the in the position where
he potentially is going to get that and
look
he
that's why that's why he's different
than the other coaches because he'll say
what he wants to say he'll say what he
believes and um you know there's a
there's a strong call to action in there
and that is a statement that that really
to me transcends statement and and in
and of itself is action because it's
sending that message to people 22 weeks
from today for change and he raises a
very good point that i think we we
i don't know that we've mentioned this
yet this week but my god think of
all the years
of mistreatment
of minorities by law enforcement
where there wasn't
evidence
that was in the palm of the hands of
anyone who was in position to press
record on their phone and and it's
amazing and astounding to think of the
things that do happen in plain sight of
the cameras you know
we're all big brother now we all have
the cameras which is on one hand a
horrible invasion of individual privacy
on the other hand it's a great way to
hold people and authority accountable
and if they're going to continue to act
the way that they acted when they're
being videotaped god only knows what
they were doing when they believed there
was no
evidence that was going to come to light
other than
a group of police officers who
understand that when push comes to shove
i didn't see anything i don't know
anything about that no i didn't do that
no he pulled the gun first even if he
didn't how many times has that happened
over the years when there wasn't video
evidence of it to be actually debunked
so uh
uh yeah uh
it's it's it's good that we're at this
moment
yeah it's necessary
that we're embracing the moment it's
horrible how we got here it's good that
we're waking up to it and the challenge
becomes taking this moment and turning
it into action it can't just be
something that subsides you know you you
follow the nfl you follow world events
things come and go it's a roller coaster
things are going to go away no matter
how intense it burns at any given moment
it always goes away and the topic
changes to something else this is a time
to grab this moment
and say how can we turn it into change
chris like what the saints
uh have done with the reaction that
they've taken creating a social justice
leadership coalition and
hey give us ideas people at pro football
talk floridafootballtalk.com
send us your ideas well i want to know
ways that we all can make a difference
right we for me
what what i try to do chris is use our
platforms to make the difference but but
but maybe there's more we can do beyond
just using the platforms and and i think
this is the moment where we all we all
need to look in the mirror and look
around and ask and think
what can we do to be part of the
solution
yeah what can we do to be part of the
solution what can we do during the
season to pay tribute to the people that
have been you know wrongfully killed and
murdered you know in these type of
incidents all of those things i mean
yeah we welcome those ideas and you know
sean payton just to get back to that i
mean i love sean payton this is why i
love him i mean where's his he wears his
heart on his sleeve he's not afraid to
do something that yeah could ruffle some
feathers you know made strong statements
a few years ago about gun control when
will smith you know his ex-player will
smith was murdered you know so that that
i really respect sean payton for that
putting himself out there for scrutiny
and people are gonna tell them to stay
out of it and don't get political and
all of that stuff too okay uh but you
know the other thing i think to look at
here just from the football angle too
with guys like you know this is where
i'm surprised more coaches haven't come
out with strong statements one one a lot
of coaches i know just throughout the
pandemic leading into this are very
frustrated with the leadership in our
country okay they are
and you you and i both know the nfl is
very republican and conservative uh by
nature for the most part that really
that really is the way it is but i think
there is frustrations there legitimately
and i think sean payton showed that with
his last little statement there on that
tweet but like the football angle of it
too mike where i'm just shocked more
coaches haven't come out and said
something strong is
man
you know like right now i look at guys
like brian flores frank wright
especially sean payton and pete carroll
they're going to corner the market on
you know african-american players or
players that are white that are woke
right the for the the new hip phrase
right the people that are their eyes are
open to the injustices going on in the
world they're gonna have a great
advantage there too signing players if a
player's in doubt and you're going okay
team a offered me this and team b
offered me this and team b is coached by
sean payton or pete carroll whatever it
is hey they're gonna they're gonna err
on going with those guys because uh they
stand for something they believe in
something and these players are gonna
like that and want to get behind that
and i think that's also why you see
these players play so hard for both of
these coaches to begin with anyways
because they realize these are two
coaches that are in their corner so uh
you know sean payton i just i can't say
enough about him and that's a really
strong statement he put out there
yesterday
and look i hope that there are no
coaches who are so cynical that they
would calculate i need to say something
strong in order to give myself an
advantage or avoid a disadvantage when
it comes to free agency i'd like to
think i prefer to think and barring out
to the contrary i will think that what
we're seeing is authentic and organic
and a reflection of who these
individuals
are and i i i i struggled the other
night
in pointing out that only a small
handful of coaches have said anything
right
coaches handle things in different ways
right that's right coaches are going to
communicate only with their players some
coaches don't want to put out a
statement anthony lynn the chargers
coach had an interview yesterday with
the la times very powerful i just didn't
want to put out a pretty statement but
i'm pissed off he said so some very
strong words from anthony lynn and
working behind the scenes with players
to get to where the team needs to be to
work through these issues process these
issues sean mcvay the rams coach spoke
yesterday about what they have done
internally to work through this the
things he have learned that he has
learned from talking to his players
listening to his players listening to
their experiences as minorities in
today's america uh there's a lot of
stuff that unless you've lived it
you need someone to open your eyes to it
and to share with you the examples of
the things they've experienced the ways
in which they have felt no doubt the
discrimination that is systemic in so
many ways even today in the year 2020
and i think a lot of us a lot of us are
just blind to it right a lot of us are
just like oh hey it's fine it's 20 20.
all that crap doesn't go on anymore all
those yeah right i'm over well they're
not guess what they're not and they're
not going to end until we all come
together and we all live
the american ideals and to the extent
that
whatever religion you practice
if it's founded on the one nation under
god concept the idea that there is a
loving god that loves us all equally
we're not different races in god's eyes
and so if you're religious if you're
american this is one area where the two
things can combine where church and
state are one we are all human beings we
are all equal we all should be treated
equal by the system whatever the system
is however the system manifests itself
we all should be regarded as equal
regardless of what we look like and and
again i think some of us just believed
we had gotten to that point and we're
learning that uh no there's still a long
way to go and now is the time
to find a way to turn words into action
and and again send me an email florio
profootballtalk.com oh oh why are you
giving out your email address i don't
care send me an email send me send me
your ideas on how we can be part of the
change on how you can be part of the
change on how we can tell others how to
be part of the change the moment is here
this is the test chris what are we going
to do with this we're going to talk
about it for a week or so until we move
on to something else or are we going to
do something about it that is the test
it's the big test and i feel like this
one might stick a little bit you know
just because again you know how many
nights in a row have we seen protests
and things like that this is this is
angered invigorated a lot of people in
our country we know that and i think
it's really woke uh a different even a
different group of people up that maybe
weren't in this fight or not realize and
all the aspects of it whatever it may be
uh and now they're joining the fight too
so i you're right i mean i hope that we
continue this and don't let this just
you know fall away or get swept under
the rug a few weeks from now when things
start to quiet down you know this is a
this is a fight that we got to continue
and it's going to take some time for us
to fix it so it's not one of these
things we can have a two or three week
conversation go okay we're all good
we're all healed everybody understands
where we're coming from no that's not
the case uh there's a lot of learning
and growing that americans need to do so
we can grow together and be a better
country
and chris the nfl needs to be part of
the change not the individual players
and coaches that's what i'm not
referring to i'm referring to the nfl
itself the organization itself it needs
to be part of the action it can't just
be work
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports